ننتقل الان الى موسكو من هناك معنا رانيا
دريدي رانيا ماذا عن هذا التقدم الروسي
يعني في في محيط وما هي التوقعات الروسيه
بشان المعارك الدائره هناك
بدايه السي يعني الجانب الروسي لا يتحدث
على الاطلاق عن اي توقعات كل ما يتعلق
بالعمليه العسكريه الروسيه على الارض في
اوكرانيا منذ بدايه منذ بدايتها العام
الماضي يعني يبقى في اطار السريه ان صح
التعبير ونحن نعلم فقط
بالمعطيات والتطورات الاوضاع على الارض
بعد السيطره على مناطق معينه او بعد اتخاذ
قرارات وخطوات معينه على الارض فيما يتعلق
بالدرجه الاولى في تطورات الوضع بضخمه
اليوم كانت هناك تصريحات لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ولفت الانتباه ان هذه التصريحات
تجنبت الحديث عن تطورات الاوضاع في باخمت
ولكن بالفعل نحن نع
مقاتلين شركه فاغنر العسكريه الروسيه
الخاصه يقاتلون على الارض بالدرجه الاولى
في مدينه باخور باخط بشكل عام في المناطق
المحيطه بهذه المدينه وامس مالك هذه
الشركه
اكد سيطرت قواته بشكل كامل ليله امس على
مدينه او بلده فرنسكافيه التي تقع شمالين
مدينه باقمت يعني الجانب الروسي اكد مرارا
خلال الايام الماضي على ان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه فضلا عن تركيزها على المعارك في
مدينه باقلوط نفسها لكنها تستمر في التمدد
في مختلف الاتجاهات في
الضواحي ومحيط هذه المدينه نحو الشمال نحو
الشمال الغربي نحو الجنوب وهي حاليا تعمل
على تضييق الخناق اكثر واكثر بهذه الطريقه
على مدينه واقمت وتحاول قطع كل امتدادات
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه الى داخل
المدينه وبالتالي تحاول السيطره على كل
المرتفعات استراتيجيه المحيطه بها بما في
ذلك السيطره على احدى اهم هذه المرتفعات
وهي مدينه فارسكا التي تم الاعلان امس عن
السيطره عليها فيما يتعلق بالتطورات
الاوضاع على وجه التحديد في مدينه باكموت
نعم هناك معارك داريا معارك داميه بحسب
وصف الجانب الروسي تجري حاليا بما في ذلك
في داخل المدينه نفسها وبحسب المعطيات
الصادره عن مختلف المصادر العسكريه التي
هناك تقدم للقوات المسلحه الروسيه في
المناطق في الجنوبيه في داخل مدينه وايضا
في المناطق الجنوبيه
الشرقيه هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى لو تحدثنا
عن التطورات على مختلف الجبهات من الواضح
ان روسيا تخوض المعارك على جبهات محدده
يعني هدم تلمسناه من معطيات وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه خلال الشهر الاخير الحديث يدور
هنا بالدرجه الاولى عن محور كوبيانس في
مقاطعه خارطف وايضا محور كراس نيمار في
وايضا محور دانياسكو دانياس الجنوبي وايضا
هناك عمليات بين فتره واخرى تنافذها
القوات المسلحه الروسيه تستهدف بها مواقع
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
بحسب المعطيات الصادره من قبل وزاره
الدفاع من الواضح خلال الايام القليله
الماضيه ال سي هناك اعداد كبيره من القوات
الاوكرانيه التي تم القضاء عليها وواضح ان
هناك ارتفاع في عدد الخسائر الاوكرانيه
اشكرك
في موسكو ون